find the slope of a line perpendicular
to the line 3x plus 2y is equal to 6.
now just as a bit of a review
let's just think about two lines that
are perpendicular so that's my x-axis
this is my y-axis
my y-axis and let's say i have one line
over here
just like that and let's say that it has
a slope
let's say that the slope over here for
this line is equal to m
now let's have a line that's
perpendicular to that line so that means
it intersects at a 90 degree angle
so let's say this line right here is
perpendicular so this right here is a 90
degree angle
then this if this purple line has a
slope of m then this green line will
have a slope
will have a slope of
negative 1 over m it is the negative
reciprocal or the negative inverse of
the slope of the magenta line and this
is obviously the negative inverse of the
green line their slopes are the negative
inverse of each other and that's what
makes them perpendicular and i won't
prove it in this video but let's just
apply that to this right over here so we
have a line 3x plus 2y is equal to 6. if
we figure out this line's slope then the
slope of a line that's perpendicular to
it will be the negative reciprocal of
that slope so let's find this guy's
slope and then the negative reciprocal
of that will be the slope of a line
that's perpendicular to it so we have
let me switch to pink
3x plus 2y is equal to 6. the easiest
way to find the slope is to put this
equation in slope intercept form where y
is equal to mx plus b form so we want to
solve for y
let's subtract 3x from both sides
so we subtract 3x from both sides
and so the left-hand side we're just
left with 2y and on the right we're left
with we could write this as six minus
three x or
negative three x plus six
now we can divide both sides of this
equation by two
so divide by two divide by two divide by
two the left-hand side we just have a y
is equal to negative three-halves x
plus
six over two is three so the slope of
this line we now wrote it in
slope-intercept form this right here is
our slope this right here is our m the
slope of this line is negative three
halves m is equal to negative three
halves so the slope of a line that's
perpendicular to this line will be the
negative will be the negative reciprocal
of this so if we take so let me write it
down
so slope
slope of perpendicular
perpendicular
line is going to be the negative
reciprocal so this is a negative number
already if we take if we take the
negative of that it's going to become a
positive number and then we have the
reciprocal instead of three halves we
will have
two thirds so they're different signs
and this is the reciprocal of that and
we are done